this Quran burner yesterday he passed
away
one of the Quran burners has died
or shall I rephrase that and say he has
taken his own life this Quran burner in
the picture it's a Quran burner that is
living in Norway
yesterday in the age of 42 he passed
away this picture on the screen is from
the 26th of November
when he was trying to destroy our dawah
stand in Oslo in Norway they get
depressed and they don't want to live
anymore and in the end they take their
own lives one of their friends who joins
them on these campaigns has taken his
own life
now the question that needs to be asked
is brothers and sisters what leads
wanting this path or finding no way out
but taking their own life
brothers and sisters it is only by the
remembrance of Allah and peace
these people who are living in this
lifestyle where they are not happy and
content and that's the reason may be the
reason that they are spewing so much
hate that their lives are not going the
way they wanted it to be because they do
not remember their lord and on top of
that instead of seeking guidance and
saying you know what I'm not happy maybe
Islam is the truth what they say no Over
My Dead Body I will not submit to Islam
If Only They stop listening to the media
lies
and the propaganda and if only instead
of burning the qurans
they chose to open it
they would have maybe get some guidance
and seek some guidance from the Quran If
Only They put their Grudge and their
hatred to a site that consumes their
very own self when they burn these
qurans they are burning their Guidance
with it
because they are shown that they do not
want to learn they do not want to know
they are stubborn and in their own ways
as Muslims now we can say you know what
rejoice sometimes it's sad sometimes to
see someone with such hatred that they
had to resort to nothing but to take
their own life
we hated him for the sake of Allah to
these actions but we expected and wanted
guidance for all but we know our Lord
knows better than us and he knows who
deserves what that's the reason why
brothers and sisters the more they Brown
could earns the more we print qurans the
more we do that were more the more we
reach thousands if not billions of
people and thousands and millions of
people come to Islam and on top of that
on top of that we try to help build a
mission in Norway which you guys know
the campaign we've been running for the
past two years to help establish that
and we are going to visit ourselves Me
Myself and the team going to go and show
you guys what's been going on they've
bought the land they've bought the place
and they are renovating it as we speak
inshallah please donate to that the
point I'm going to say is this and I'm
going to end on this I don't want to
talk too much a lot of non-muslims use
the Versa Surah Toba is seen as a a
verse or a chapter all about war not
really yes of course it is but the point
is what brothers and sisters the point
is the following Allah did not send
Surah Toba came later on and you know
why because Allah sent a guidance over
guidance warning overwhoning that's why
Allah says we do not punish a nation
until we send the messenger Allah used
one of his attributes he's got many
names
yes and many attributes but Allah
specifically uses his name Bismillah
Allah the most merciful the very
merciful yes so the point is what Allah
uses this Allah uses his Mercy to show
you that to turn to him do not despair
his Mercy only in one chapter he does
not start the chapter with Bismillah
but he goes straight to say the
following and here is why Allah says
this is a declaration of this
Association from Allah's Messenger to
Those whom you have made the treaty
among the polytheists so so travel
freely among so travel freely or this
Believers throughout the land during
four months but know that you cannot
cause failure to Allah and Allah will
disgrace the disbelievers and it is an
announcement from Allah and his
Messenger to the people of the day of
the great pilgrimage that Allah
disassociates from the disbelievers and
so is so does his messenger so if you
repent that is best for you but if you
turn away way then know that you will
not cause failure to Allah and give
and give tithing to those who disbelieve
of a painful punishment except are those
who are who you made a treat among the
polyphies and then they have not been
deficient towards you and anything was
supported anyone against you so complete
for them they treat you to unto their
hand unto their term has ended indeed
Allah loves the righteous yes and when
the inviable moms have passed then it
says wage war now the point is the
following yeah the point is that these
verses came later on it talks about the
polyphies it talks about the Christians
and it talks about the Jews but if you
look and notice for years on end Allah
and his messenger has been calling for
peace stop persecuting us we are just
saying that we worship God and God alone
stop persecuting us gave them chance of
a chance chance of a chance chance of a
chance over and over again until and if
it was anyone else any other Nation any
other group of people they would even
they would have implemented this way
before
so even this is a mercy that saying that
enough is enough but if we look at it
from the sense that God Almighty has
given this person and many people like
him chance over chance change your ways
learn
guidance and when they act with nothing
but hostility then indeed Allah's
punishment will come in this life and in
the hereafter
that's all I want to say
and we ask Allah to make us amongst
those who are just
and make us among those who seek the
truth and get rid of this stubbornness
and this Grudge instead of burning
qurans open it open it and read it with
an open mind and say maybe the truth is
here and if you don't indeed you deserve
a painful punishment
and like they say instead of questioning
if your if Allah is the most merciful
why would he put people on the fire
rather ask yourself this question what
kind of a wretched person you was that
you went past and avoided all of Allah's
mercy and all of his guidance and chose
Hellfire continue donating to the Norway
Mr Bob and sisters and allow us to turn
that hostility under hatred these people
have innately that consumed themselves
to do something positive for Humanity at
Large
till next time